is the Quran the word of God
so the Quran and this is what
distinguishes the Quran in many ways uh
from other scriptures so as Muslims we
do believe
that God has sent divine revelation
prior we believe that the Original
Scriptures
prior to the multiple versions and
the changes and revisions throughout
history The Original Scriptures that
were given to the prophets whether it
was the Torah
to Moses or the Gospels
were all original Divine Revelations but
they've been changed over time the Quran
is the word of God with a promise that
he will guard it for all of time and
it's probably one of the greatest
Miracles because in 1400 years
we have the Quran preserved through oral
transmission and through written
transmission
and there are almost 2 billion Muslims
in the world and they all recite this
book the exact same way and there's only
one version of it and so when I'm
reciting the Quran if I say U or e or ah
differently
an Ethiopian Muslim a Chinese Muslim a
yemeni Muslim can correct me an
eight-year-old kid in any one of those
countries can correct me because they
will know that this is not how it's
memorized and so it was memorized from
the start committed to memory in the
time of the Prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him and preserved in writing and
passed down and memorized by millions
and millions of people around the world
and it's 600 pages
and you can't go to a city in America
a city in the United States of America
and not find at least one person or a
group of people that memorize it that
have committed it to memory and so
there's an emphasis on committing it to
memory as well as understanding it and
applying it and practicing it as much as
we can
what are some
maybe deep or insightful differences
between the Quran the Torah and the
Bible
well like I said so so you've got the
original Revelations of those scriptures
but there are so many versions of those
scriptures and there are times
throughout history where there have been
changes just from an objective
perspective right uh
what is the original scripture that was
given to uh Moses peace be upon him and
what was initially communicated to Jesus
peace be upon him those things
um have changed over time
however there's still some truth that
remains even in those scriptures and so
there are still things that line up
especially with the Old Testament and
Islam there are still many things that
line up between the two
the Bible as well the New Testament now
Matthew Mark Luke and John it's it's
different because these are not uh
Original Scriptures these are
testimonies that were obviously
collected
around the entire phenomenon of the
coming of Christ but the authors
themselves the biographies
the documentation even of those original
testimonies and gospels what made the
cut in terms of being included within
the gospels and what didn't because
there are many gospels at the time in
that sense it's different from what we
believe was scripture communicated to
Jesus peace be upon him
the Quran is different in several ways
but it confirms uh what came before it
but it's the document and preserved word
of God to be recited throughout
throughout time so it confirms much of
what came before it
and it resides amongst us and within us
for for the rest of time and through it
we honor those Revelations that came
through the prophets of old
because the essence the core of what
came through those Revelations is
preserved in the Quran and with us I
tell people this all the time that you
know the prophet Muhammad peace be upon
Him introduced
uh Jesus peace be upon him and even
Moses peace be upon him to much of the
world
there are Muslims around the world that
are named ASA that are named Jesus there
are Muslims around the world that are
named Ibrahim Abraham Muslims around the
world named Musa and they learned of
these figures through the Revelation
that came to the prophet Muhammad peace
be upon Him Noah
Maryam one of the most popular names in
Islam Mary peace be upon her whole
chapter in the Quran named after
Mariam which is actually what I was
reciting in the prayer was the chapter
of Maryam the chapter of the story of
Mary peace be upon her so the Quran
contains the stories it contains
um
legislation and law but primarily it was
revealed over 23 years so it actually
was coming in accordance with some of
the events that were unfolding the life
of the Prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him
the first 13 years of that was primarily
belief in God uh belief in the Hereafter
and things that surrounded the court
Creed of Islam and then legislation law
stories of the prophets uh came down in
accordance with the unfolding events as
well as prophesizing some of the things
that were to come
and speaking about some of the things
that just happened and it is completed
in the lifetime of the Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon and memorized and then
communicated to generation after
generation after generation so that we
have it in its pristine Fashions now
billions of people yeah just all across
the world all the different cultures all
memorizing the same words